any kind of cause like this we love to
to help out as much as we can this one
was just just happened to be this one
happened to hit home Nickelback was
formed just six hours away from Fort
McMurray in Hana Alberta they were ready
to fly anywhere any time to perform and
breathe life into the hearts of their
fellow Canadians when we saw the images
it was like it just looked like a war
zone it looked like someone had dropped
a bomb you look at that and you say that
doesn't happen here that doesn't company
and so it was just you just in shock
people will rebuild that's what makes
the community everyone wants to see that
town rebuild and come back stronger than
ever when a disaster happens if any kind
it's hard to really put yourself in that
place unless you're there and when you
hear all the stories it's just I had
somebody send a semi video there their
family were RCMP and Fort McMurray range
is showing just basements that's always
left just how tough was it to drag
yourself away from being in the middle
of recording a wreck Xbox and golf no no
we just came from rehearsals we haven't
played in a year I hope it's okay
we're not sure CIL's were a little rocky